you know some of the best things we get
in this life are through the choices
that we make
like choosing which video game to buy
hint buy a zelda game
or choosing who you'd like to lead your
country next or
choosing what pair of wireless earbuds
you'd like let me offer you a little
piece of advice
choose raycon specifically their new
everyday e25 earbuds
not only do they come in this cute
little charging case that carries four
complete charges without even having to
plug it back in
but they fit so snugly in your ears that
they won't fall out even if you're
scaling
death mountain their re-engineered noise
isolating base
boosting sound quality will keep you
jamming even if you're standing beside
the noise of lake highly as waterfalls
they even come in some fantastic colors
so you can choose to style exactly how
you want to
and i don't know if you've noticed but
it's getting pretty close to the end of
the year
and the end of the year means holidays
and holidays means gifts
and let me tell you pretty good gift
ideas since anybody can use them at any
time whether they're staying at home or
going outdoors
and you my friends are in luck because
right now
right now is the only time of year to
get the best price ever on raycon
earbuds click the link in the
description below or go to www
mmb for a whopping 20 off your order
this offer is only around for an
extremely limited amount of time so what
are you waiting for
go check today and without further ado
follow me into the video
all right let's get these lights turned
off man
[Music]
have you ever stopped to consider just
how dark of a game breath of the wild
really is
i mean yes it's got cute puppers running
around and beetle and some genuinely
feel good quests
but if you think about it aside from the
happy-go-lucky content
it's also got everything from little
children crying for their mothers that
will never return
to potentially demonic forces
manipulating life itself
to the biggest one being the entire game
built upon the corpses of the heroes who
died in battle 100 years ago
as you more than likely are very
familiar with by now the game takes
place after a hundred year time lapse
from the re-emergence of one calamity
ganon who properly wrecked
everything when he brought about the
second great calamity he took control of
the shika technologies that the
hyruleans were hoping to use against him
and proceeded to kill
not only the vast majority of the
residents of hyrule but also its
king and his chosen champions mipha
daruk
urbosa and the dumb flying one and ever
since we were pleasantly informed of the
new hyrule warriors game coming in just
a few days that will focus on the events
of 100 years ago
i and many other breath of the wild fans
and theorists have been wondering about
whether or not we'll get to witness the
champion's deaths
since we know that's what happens before
the events of the original game but all
this
wondering and speculating and theorizing
about what we could see in just a few
days when it releases to the public
got me wondering about something else
regarding their deaths you see
we see glimpses of what is probably
going to be their downfalls in the
trailer to age of calamity but what we
don't see
is really any other deaths at all
including what exactly was responsible
for killing them
of course veteran players will
automatically remember that the four
different blight ganons that were each
fought either at the end of the divine
beast dungeons or before calamity ganon
himself were responsible for killing the
champions a fact that's backed up by the
voices of the champions themselves
but there are some key details that led
me to come to some conclusions about the
nature of both the blight cannons and
the champion spirits that i think you'll
find very interesting
and it all stems from one burning
question
where are their bodies now i know what
you're probably thinking
mr bandit you're reading a little too
far into this i mean they don't have to
show
dead bodies in a game rated e10 and up
and i agree
however my argument here is that we
should remember how dark the undertones
of this game really are
and the fact that they might have
actually already shown us the bodies we
just didn't realize that that's what
they were at the time
but let me back up and start from the
beginning the first dead person we see
is also the first person we see in
general the old man who was revealed to
be none
other than the king of hyrule himself
having died 100 years ago in the second
great calamity it is important to note
that even though we see the old man
literally wearing clothes starting fires
holding axes cooking and many other
pretty normal actions for any other
living human being
he was still dead the whole time meaning
these spirits in breath of the wild can
materialize and dematerialize and
manipulate the physical world at will
while still being
you know dead but if this were the case
for just any dead individual in the
universe of hyrule there would be all
sorts
of these spirits walking around
disappearing and reappearing and moving
stuff all over the place
i think it's safe to say that these high
spirits the king and his champions
were a bit special wouldn't you say
they're clearly not just your average
ordinary ghost wandering around with
unfinished
business looking for whoever ate their
french fries without asking
they were powerful individuals who were
anchored to this plane of existence for
a
very specific purpose or by a very
specific
being at the end of the game we see the
five spirits ascend and fade away
into nothingness after link and zelda
defeat ganon implying their duty was
fulfilled and therefore their spirits
are no longer lingering on in our realm
but i believe the champion spirits being
tied to their duty of defeating ganon
was not just born out of a sense of duty
but was also
a literal bond you see when i tried
thinking about what all these high
spirits had in common with each other
that would make them come back as these
unique
ghosts my first instinct was to say it
was the connection to their divine
beasts however
this doesn't work for the king as he
doesn't have a divine beast of his own
unless you think hyrule castle may be a
divine beast like my theory i did with
nintendo black crisis that i will link
to in the description below but
anyway the only thing each of these
spirits actually all have in common is
gannon or gannon z with the blight
canons being linked to each champion's
divine beast and calamity ganon being
linked to the king's hyrule castle
so what if the high spirits of the king
and his champions are linked to the
ganons
because they are the ganons okay i know
that
last bit sounds a bit like a fever dream
at this present time but hold on i'm
about to start explaining things
firstly since they all came back as
these high spirits that means they were
all killed in similar ways and due to
their last known positions when they
died with the champions heading to their
divine beasts and the king most likely
being defeated in the castle
and the positions of the ganons it can
be assumed that all of these spirits
including the king were killed
by malice ganons that's all well and
good but now let's start talking about a
couple weird things with the blight
ganons you see i always thought it was a
bit
strange how similar they are to the
champions
and the more you think about it the
stranger things get
take their attacks for example wind
blight ganon flies high around in the
air
has excellent aim and shoots harmful
tornado winds at you
fire blight ganon uses a very familiar
looking overshield and swings a giant
weapon
water by ganon fills the room with water
and throws spears at you like a zora
and thunderblite ganon has long hanging
hair zips around with the power of
lightning and fights with a sword and
shield combo like a garuda warrior there
are several questions that come to mind
with the fact that these blight canons
defeated the champions in combat 100
years ago
firstly the champions were all unrivaled
fighters that could each easily defeat
hordes of monsters by themselves
i know that hyrule warrior's gameplay is
probably not the most canon thing to go
by but if it is even remotely accurate
as to the actual power levels of these
champions
they were definitely at or near the
power level of link himself who later
defeats the blight ganons
secondly the blight's powers such as
thunderblight's lightning or
fireblight's overshield are clearly
copied from the champions they defeated
and those powers are shown to come from
the champions themselves not the divine
beasts as we see that they can each use
their abilities outside of the giant
machines
meaning the blights must have gotten
them directly from the champions
themselves
and thirdly in a game that focuses on
countering elements and finding
elemental weaknesses
you really expect to believe that these
blight gannons used the very same
elements that the champions were experts
with
to defeat them if anything you would
think water blight ganon was sent to
kill erbosa or thunder blight ganon was
sent to kill mifa
but we know that what happened is
actually the opposite
however there is one solution that
answers all of these questions that i
mentioned earlier
what if the blight gannons are the
champions
calamity ganon sent his malice into the
world of hyrule to capture the powerful
sheikah technologies right however a
divine beast can't just be captured and
reprogrammed the same as he did with the
guardians because a divine beast
is not automated it must be piloted so
what if
to convert the divine beasts ganon sent
the blights to actually possess
the champions making them his pilots
possession is something ganon is shown
to be all too eager and familiar with in
the past
zelda games and it actually makes a ton
of sense for the blight ganons to
literally be the twisted
malicious possessed forms of the
champions bodies complete with their
control over the divine beasts and their
powers
and think about it what if the ganons
are only able to be ganons because they
have bodies they can use for material
and once you defeat all of calamity
ganon at the end of the game
it releases their tie to this world and
they are then able to ascend
into the afterlife the only one of these
high spirits i don't have quite as much
proof for would be the king of hyrule
since calamity ganon actually just uses
all of the blight ganon's powers in
combat against link
but this could also just be calamity
again and annexing the blights back
into himself after they were defeated as
far as i can tell the king didn't have
any powers of his own either so calamity
ganon not having
any unique powers actually kind of makes
sense and even if the blights aren't the
actual legitimate malice possessed
bodies of the champions
the fact that they move and fight like
the champions is still very interesting
to say the least
and i think it's pretty safe to say that
some sort of infusion had to have
happened at some point
and i know the notion of link actually
killing the possessed champions of 100
years ago is pretty dark and halloween
is already over
but i guess let's just pretend it's
still halloween season just for today oh
and also please keep in mind that
even though i stated in my previous
video that i'm beginning to feel like
age of calamity may turn out to not be
canon
that is still just a theory and if it
actually does end up being canon and
portrays accurately the events of a
hundred years ago then in just a few
days we'll all get to see if this theory
is true or not
but until then if you enjoyed watching
let me know what you thought in the
comments below and please consider
leaving a like to get the video spread
around on youtube
also if you would be so kind as to
subscribe to the channel for much more
juicy nintendo content to come i
solemnly promise you
you will be glad you did thanks so much
for watching and as always a huge thanks
to my supporters for supporting i have a
new face to announce so please say hello
to musical lyricist
who recently joined the ranks of my
elite over on patreon if you're
interested in helping me put food on the
table and receiving some epic benefits
click that join button located below
each video or follow the links in the
description below to find out how also
down there are links to my social media
pages so come keep up with me over on
instagram that's all i've got for this
one so as always i will see you next
time and hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is massentinabandit signing out
[Music]
you